we're seconds away from season two of
the drew barrymore show that you say go
big or go home but we're gonna do both
fire this thing up
because there truly is no place like
home i'm going coast to coast from new
york to california and everywhere in
between to celebrate all our hometowns
so let's do this from the place i was
born and raised hello hollywood this is
the true barrymore show
[Applause]
hello everybody
hello hello
welcome
i can't believe we're here
this is all for you guys and it means so
much to all of us because
you
are our very first in-person studio
audience
[Applause]
we didn't have the privilege of that in
year one and what a way to kick things
off we are here in my hometown of
hollywood
at the iconic
paramount studio
my grandfather john barrymore
shot here
i love that hello hello
i am so excited for our very first guest
she may be the biggest star on the
planet
we've worked together we've laughed
together
and i cannot believe
right now that we're actually here
together
it's total kismet because she's here to
help us
kick off our second season of this
daytime show
i know
as she
jumps into the second season of her
upcoming series the morning show and
when i say that acting doesn't get
better than this i mean it with every
fiber of my being please welcome
the magnanimous jennifer aniston
[Applause]
some of that
[Applause]
this is
first of all seeing you in the in the
flesh because i've been watching this
and you're so good
you're so good
at this
honestly i love every single bit of it
you get stains out of you i mean i oh
someone said to me
oh what was what is it
well i've already put a stain on your
chair because in my body makeup
you're like dying for that right this
has been in your blood for a long time
yes yes it really did start when i was
like 14 living in my first apartment and
there was a laundromat down the street
and i would get into that
washer like it was a cauldron and i was
a witch
fabric softener stain removal bleach the
whole art of and i think that's where it
was born so it also that holds the
sentence 14 my own apartment
it's you know where this girl has lived
it well we're going through a journey
today yes and i wanted to take this
intimate tour of los angeles
that really showed
every place that i've lived do you still
have the house that i've been to a few
times i sold it actually i know that was
a very painful thing for me a very scary
thing for me to leave my one anchor that
was your anchor when you moved from new
york
to l.a yeah
what were the feelings what was that
experience like
to let go and start anew yeah well
let go and start a new i don't think
anybody moving going from new york to la
everest actually says i'm moving you
there you're going on a vacation
that then just keeps extending itself
because you're almost too afraid to say
as an actor i'm gonna go try to make it
in california because if you i didn't
make it in new york for two years god
knows i'm gonna make it in la so i'm
just to go visit my father
and then i landed and i knew one person
and then i met another person
who then let introduced and then i went
to this little
party like a little house party in
laurel canyon maybe 12 people next thing
you know
i'm in a goddess circle
in laurel canyon
and i all of a sudden had someone i
couldn't just talk you have a talking
stick
i was like wow i am really i have landed
in los angeles
and then i was i i got a job at a
telemarketing company like in what east
i don't even know where it was
uh selling selling pocono time shares
and then i did get a a job so i moved
from studio city
with i met these people these were this
group of people and they all had rentals
on this street in laurel canyon called
beach knoll road yep um
one lived here one lived here one lived
here and they would all sort of visit
each other there was one house that
everyone kind of congregated in
and then one night i was there they're
like this one's available for rent
so then i got myself up on the hill
and we were called the hill people
lived this fun few years doing jobs here
and there and
then friends happened which i thought i
kind of manifested because i said this
is sort of the way i live on the hill
where
you have your friends
and everybody shows up at the house um
at monica and rachel's
i was like i feel very this is very
familiar to me do you believe
that you do manifest things like one is
capable of manifesting
i've been told
to manifest you whatever it is that you
are wanting to manifest
you
you speak to it as though it's already
happened okay i like that
so thank you for
this wonderful job
that i have
dreamed about and prayed for
and i with this glorious crew and a
joyful experience thank you for that
now
it's hard to like pass by the
career that you've had and jump to the
next one and then we're gonna go
backwards but
adam sandler
who is
someone
that the sandman the sandman the sandman
can adam is he's one of a kind isn't he
he's a unicorn yes he really is he's a
unicorn because he's a joy he walks with
joy lives with joy and he doesn't get
moody yeah comedians are moody and i'm
attracted to them because i want them to
make me laugh in real life yes and let
your girlfriends do that yeah totally
yeah okay so there was this uh twitter
debate that happened about who is a
better partner for adam sandler jennifer
aniston or drew barrymore which sounds
weird to say my name
and
what i loved about what came out of that
was what
well that you and i chose each other oh
well that's a no-brainer
yeah
that's because
you know the there's the the
the phrase the guys like to say you know
bros before hoes oh my god i was gonna
say hoes before bros always
and that is sisterhood that's right and
we have had that
and you have it with your friends and we
just celebrate that and i loved that
that was the true answer yeah we've got
to take a quick break but she's not
going anywhere we'll have more with
jennifer aniston right after this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please don't make me go back in there
come on i'm saying yes as a friend alex
we don't know what's going to be in
maggie's book
oh
that sounds like you do know what's
going to be in maggie's book no i don't
i know her editor but she won't tell me
but whatever it is this gives you the
opportunity to go in there and respond
without looking like you're responding
to defend yourself jesus what am i
defending myself about that i didn't
already admit on national television
welcome back we are here with america's
sweetheart and someone who just is the
coolest person on the planet jennifer
aniston
you know the morning show yes
what are you channeling in that because
it's the greatest thing i've ever seen
as an actress and in your body of work
it was basically about just revisiting
some of the
shadows blind spots that i put into a
particular file
and
meeting them head-on and actually
releasing them it was like a
extraordinary therapy
better than any actual therapist that
i've been going to for years on end
because do you think that alex levy is
the closest character to you or that
you've blessed it
with some of your deepest truths
yeah i think it's a little bit of both
alex levy is people someone maybe in
particular who i have witnessed in my
life people
say a combination of people who i have
watched
and and remember thinking
i don't want to ever do that i don't
want to be that then there is sort of
the tapping into the part that wants to
have that scream into your pillow and
yell which i never was able to do
because
until i did it in front of 150
crewmember because you wouldn't let
yourself i wouldn't let myself
i didn't know how to
i like to discuss things like to have a
conversation a rational conversation
because if you're ever with someone
who's a screamer nothing gets done i
just go shut down shut down shut down
what was it about this point in your
life that you were like i've was it and
i have nothing to lose it's written it
was written for me it was written for me
it was written we talked about it
there's there's a part as you get older
that you just hit a wonderful
who gives a rat
this is just my
right
yes
um
i thank you for sharing that with the
world
uh because it's cathartic for us
watching it thank you i'm serious it's i
mean i just marvel i marvel i marvel and
marvel i can't wait to do a comedy let
me tell you that
well rush me to a comedy immediately i
don't after completing that second
season i mean now when i think of hair
obviously you're the most famous head of
hair we've got
seriously sad i mean come on the rachel
hello
so when i hear that you're doing hair
care i'm like give it to me now
i'm on the feeder tell me about lola v
it comes out of many years of having
really unruly hair and that's always
been my struggle i paired myself with
these wonderful people that used to be
part of arden and maybe five years ago
we've started working on this
and it's we're doing one product at a
time
because it has to be perfect and that
was the first one we started because i
live for a good detangler
because when you know you rip through
your hair when it's wet is half the
damage i heard a hot tip when your hair
is wet
use a wide tooth comb because your
follicle is at its most fragile yes
please do not use a brush and break
through it especially a really bristly
brush is your is death or there's
actually wet brushes that are made for
wet hair i do love that wet brush i love
a wet brush i just discovered it oh my
god i have minis for my kids and they're
all there are minis yes they can travel
with them oh god i'm gonna get you so
many wet brushes you're not gonna i'm
just not gonna know what to do with
myself okay we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break and then when we come
back we're gonna put jen and some of our
game skills to the test oh boy and we're
gonna play the classic game show let's
make a deal because wayne brady himself
is here
to play
and we might have something important
for dogs in it great i hope this is all
about you and the rescues we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
we're back with a very charming jennifer
aniston and we're about to play
let's make a deal to hopefully win some
money for these puppies from wagmore
pets a dog rescue and you have a very
special connection with wagmore i do my
latest
lord chesterfield was rescued from
wagmore well everyone knows that i love
a game show and who doesn't what better
way to kick off los angeles week then a
classic game show let's make a deal
so everybody welcome wayne brady
[Applause]
thank you for honoring us with your
presence what was my pleasure i just
visited you and your premier week yes
ma'am so thank you for coming today tell
us what we are playing for all right so
if you know let's make a deal you know
that we love to make a deal of course so
we're going to play a game called how
much is enough
now easy peasy game this first prize
that you're playing for it is
a picture of us on the set of let's make
a deal now do you keep this picture as
amazing as it is and just walk away it's
yours or do you take a silver envelope
and that silver envelope will be brought
into me by the money fairy aka chris
ahern one of our producers thank you
money fairy
with all due respect to both of us i
think i'm going to go with the silver
yeah super envelope now you know this
could be a zonk a zonk but it isn't it's
25 000. oh my god
so you've got 25 000
for wag more
now you can keep your 25 000
and your picture and just walk away
or you could take this gold envelope
if
you decide to take the gold envelope and
there's a zonk inside then you lose
everything
[Applause]
what do you say i'm going to say that
sounds like under pressure we're going
to go for yesterday please gosh remember
when i said that if this was a zonk
you'd lose it yes we remember okay
i just gotta reiterate i know
another twenty five thousand dollars
another twenty five thousand dollars to
wag more you now have fifty thousand
dollars
plus the picture
which i'm so happy that you get that
because i'm a dog dad i've got four dogs
gay wagons gay
money fairy the big envelope please
thank you
if this is a zonk you lose everything so
you can walk away right now with your 50
grand remember we talked about not
wanting to be greedy and not being
ambitious i think we stick we're the
worst i do too stick it so you're
passing on the envelope oh come on
oh my goodness yes you guys have shot
films all all over the world have you
ever shot in hungary
no
no no he hates the idea and i'm
hungarian okay
because what you passed on
this is a zonk
and
little known that zonk is actually the
hungarian translation of he's just not
that into you
so
congratulations you missed out on a zomb
let's hear it for wagmore
miss anderson drew thank you so much so
much thank you
thank you thank you
you are so cute thank you so much that's
fifty thousand dollars and fifty
thousand dollars is
by the way come on don't pee on me baby
all right
i think it it's good
um all right that's fifty thousand
dollars and it'll go towards wag more
pets dog rescue
which jennifer aniston has brought to
the forefront of our attention it's an
extraordinary organization right here
but you can support it from all across
the country we want to send a huge thank
you
to the wildest your go-to pet parent
site and pet dna decoder wisdom panel
for your donations and supporting
wagmore pets dog rescue
those are the two companies that gave us
the 25 thousand dollars yay and thank
you so much for supporting wagamore go
to the drewberrymore show.com to find
out more information on the wildest
wisdom panel and wag more pets dog
rescue and wayne thank you so much for
doing this thanks for having me pleasure
to see you be sure to check out let's
make a deal today on cbs
the morning show premieres september
17th on apple tv
we'll be right back thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to our season 2 premiere
show coming to you from sunny los
angeles california
we really do have amazing weather here
and uh today we're celebrating a drew
getter right here
um and she's from watts south los
angeles and has spent the last 50 years
educating children
from underserved communities take a look
at her
story hi
i'm delora sheen aka antalorus and i'm
the executive director and co-founder of
the xinhua school and culture center in
watts south la the school opened in 1971
50 years ago
and we're still
here reaching out to teaching
i was going to be a doctor i dropped out
of school
took montessori courses so i could be an
educator our curriculum is
enriched and we use everything we can in
our power to develop and encourage
critical thinking sign language drama
music we have a cricket club
the first cricket club in the hood i
teach harp
violin cello bass piano we had all these
pumpkins in our little garden and that's
how the shenway bakery was born
the chow wagon was launched on
juneteenth of this year to allow the
children to serve the community come get
your delicious pumpkin bread
i'm never going to retire because as
long as i can give i think i'll live
it's a good feeling when you know that
someone's going to walk out
knowing more than they did when they
came in and you had a part of it i think
that's why i love children so much
sorry
it's like
good in the hood
welcome live and in person dolores sheen
aka aunt dolores
you and i understand you brought two
special gentlemen here today yeah some
good cooks oh
this is
this is marcus and that's jordan
marcus i'd like to ask what your
favorite thing is about being a part of
this community
it's fun
education i love that you summed up one
word that speaks volumes
and jordan what about for you i like the
food
i think something all
people can relate to and appreciate and
you also have sheen way sister school in
ghana africa will you please tell us
about that program
our school here is an underserved area
of what they call south la in the hood
our school in ghana is in the bush it's
like an underserved area we were the
first registered private school in the
boulder region
um
and you guys brought some baked goods
for us and these are treats from the
sheen way bakery right yes the students
own and operate their bakery because
there's a history of why we have the
bakery and the history stems from when
the community and richard pryor helped
us get a peace treaty with the bloods
and the cryptids to the main gang
factions
and we wanted to say thank you and that
year we had a lot of pumpkins in our
garden so i said let's try to make some
pumpkin bread and they said let's give
richard pryor some so he loved the
pumpkin bread and that's how the bakery
got started and not only that he came
back three times to talk with the
dialogue and that set a different
perspective on the community like
someone knows we're here someone knows
our pain
that was more than any money or anything
anybody could give and to this day he is
our hero
the
layers of importance and beauty just
keep unfolding and we also have some
special people joining us right here in
the audience who are proud of you and
what you have done for your community
please welcome principal roy sadakane
faculty and alumni from machine way
school hello
[Applause]
i love that principal roy what is your
hope for sheen way in the next 50 years
currently as entrepreneurs had mentioned
we're uh we have a school in sassacope
ghana and we're starting a new digital
infrastructure that will connect los
angeles our los angeles school to the
school in south copa ghana well you're
going to
support
and you deserve that and to commemorate
your 50th anniversary our friends at
conagra brands foundation are donating
twenty thousand dollars
[Applause]
thank you
thank you dolores
thank you marcus and jordan
principal roy and everyone at the
sheenway school and cultural center in
watts for more information you can go on
our website at thedrewberrymareshow.com
to support this incredible institution
and we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome back i still cannot believe that
we get to launch our second season
from hollywood
to make the most of this moment right
now
and honor it in a way it truly deserves
i wanted to take a look back
at some of the places that shaped me
and i wanted to take you with me
this is an intimate tour of my l.a
i'm going to take us to
the
first place i lived until i was seven
years old
hang on to your hat
they really made it look so much more
romantic
the bars were on the windows because it
just wasn't safe enough but the
neighborhood's gotten so much better
god i'm so tempted to just beg them to
let me in
[Music]
i
i don't
have to be lonely anymore
i was so lonely in this house
it was just me and my mom and it was it
was just a really sad
energy
it was very empty and very lonely
and um
you know i grew up and got in charge of
my own destiny and now my house is like
grand central station
there's so
much life
and there's so many people
and this place just taught me that i
wasn't the kind of person who wanted to
live in a
quiet
lonely place
i wanted to live a life where i was
around a lot of people
[Music]
i learned to drive at sophia lorenz
ranch in calabasas
her two sons carlo and eduardo taught me
in a renault la car and they taught me
on a stick shift
[Music]
oh my god when i was trying to attempt
sleeping at night even though i was just
so scared
this is what cats sound like when they
are mating are you ready
[Music]
that was the soundtrack to this
apartment
as much as the building looks charming
back in the 70s there was a lot of like
don't park your car at night alone
there's bars on the windows there's bars
on the individual apartments i mean for
a 14 year old i was like
i was scared
and um
i'm not scared anymore
i'm not scared anymore at all
i definitely
am glad that my kids
no matter what because we're gonna
all of us are gonna screw it up with our
kids we're gonna do our best but we're
gonna make mistakes
i'm so glad that my kids won't be having
to live on their own at 14.
and that's as healing to the 14 year old
me
as it can get
this is it
oh my god it's still here the washing
machine
this is such a dream to be here i spent
years here when i first lived in my
apartment that i was so scared and the
truth was is that i
would let the laundry and dishes and
everything pile up i didn't know how to
clean
but this was where i learned how to take
care of myself you know the books were
the school and this was like the
domestic journey of learning how to live
on your own
kids don't know how to take care of
themselves
until you teach them
olive and frankie i'm coming for you
[Music]
that was the start of my stain removal
story you know we have a segment on our
show called stand for stains
and um i absolutely just loved taking
this tour and sharing it with you that's
why i did it
um including our last stop it's a place
i haven't been back to in a long time
it's the institution where i spent a
year and a half of my life
um and
take a look
it's right here
the place was all the barbed wire yeah
that's it
i was a real wild child
and i just got so out of control that
no one knew what to do with me
and so my mom
called a friend because her daughter was
out of control and
they drove me here in the middle of the
night and they walked me right through
those two doors
and when you go through those two doors
you do not come out
um and i was there for a year and a half
i think this is important for me
to share with people because when they
watch our show we have a very beautiful
set
and
i get to
dress in nice clothing
and get my hair and makeup done
and
there's an elegance hopefully to the
show
but i will never lose sight of this part
of my story
and i have seen and been through things
and they've helped
me
just recognize in all of us that we go
through stuff
and it can't be embarrassing it has to
be our strengths
it has to be something that we can be
proud of because we overcame it and we
look back with honor
and humor
my life is so wonderful compared to what
it was in this place
i can't even believe i
actually get to
be where i am now
because when i was here i didn't see
that i thought i would be here forever i
never thought i was gonna make it
to somewhere better
and i'm just
so happy with my life
and i don't know if i would have the
life i have if it wasn't for a place
like this so
it was so important to come here today
just like
honor this
it's very empowering
it's very celebratory
i just get to visit it in my dreams and
wave hello and no i'm not here anymore
that's pretty cool
welcome to the drew barrymore show
where we like to keep it real
thank you for taking the time to
be so intimate with me i really
appreciate it and there's so much more
actually to this tour so if you go to
our website at thedrewberrymartial.com
right now you can watch the full version
and uh we will be right back
[Music]
hollywood is simply one of the coolest
places in cali it happens to be where i
was born and raised and lived my whole
life in the 9046 area code
there are so many reasons to visit this
area the iconic hollywood sign is
certainly one of them but there is
amazing food and interesting
neighborhoods to walk around an old
spanish hollywood architecture to marvel
at
by the way could you tell i'm from
california
i mean
i am stuck with this accent for my whole
life and i couldn't be more proud if
there's anything more cally about
someone than this kind of accent i'd
like to meet them
drew's cali is sponsored by visit
california
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back
cheers it's time for drew's news the
only news that wonders how you've been
all summer and with me at the desk
this season the co-pilot of my news
dreams rossi ross
matthew we're back
i have missed you so much and what a way
to kick off season two drew i mean i was
a girl alone in a box until you came and
rescued me ross oh
i was your knight in shining armor you
are my knight in shining armor or like
night in sequence but i'll take it thank
you drew true true true all right we're
gonna jump right in with this epic movie
news apparently everyone in hollywood is
starring in don't look up and it's the
new movie by adam mckay adam mckay has
done everything vice anchorman
uh big short yes he's a genius um the
trailer is out now and variety reports
that leonardo dicaprio is so hot and
jennifer lawrence also so hot
star as two astronomers trying to save
the world from total destruction
it's a reality movie
um thank god just kidding it's not it's
fictional take a look
there's a comet headed directly towards
earth do you know how many the world is
ending meetings we've had over the last
two years drought famine pulling the
ozone is so boring
i mean meryl streep is the freaking
president yes
uh
meryl streep you got my vote thank you
so much i i want her to be the president
for real i know secretary of state diane
keaton i'll take it absolutely diane
please come on this show we are
i mean
please we we stalk her we stand diane
keaton i mean hello hello
you look like the annie hall of fame
right now
miss diane keaton please take my hand in
fashion marriage
and please grace us with your presence
god we love her so much and guess what
what we have more good news ross oh yeah
so jennifer lawrence did you hear this
uh should people report she's got a bun
in the oven and it's not sourdough she
is expecting her first child with her
husband art gallery director cook
moroney
[Music]
i love her so much and do you know what
what you call it when a pregnant
jennifer um lawrence has cravings
hunger games
[Laughter]
you know what um no don't play out there
i have a story about jennifer lauren
tell me everything okay i was at lunch
with her me and cameron diaz so we're in
the restaurant and um
we see this guy outside and
he looks like a paparazzi
and um he's on a moped and he's got
cameras and we're like oh we're all in
the restaurant and we you know we just
showed up looking
crappy and we're all just like oh god
it's that moment
and um we're like you know what let's
just go out and uh he was a nature
photographer had no interest in us
and why did we feel stupid
and it was hilarious that we all just
had a big laugh at our own expense oh i
love that you're like oh he
he doesn't care at all about the three
of us he is a bird watcher i know but he
missed like the best picture ever can
you imagine
wow okay
i'm very interested to get your take on
this next story rossi because a new
study from the american institute of
physics found that heterosexual women
consistently rated men who speak
less clearly
are more attractive
what what what
the mumbling got these ladies motors a
rumblin
and now previous science found that
straight men on the other hand were more
attracted to women who clearly speak and
enunciate
you heard me oh i heard you we're gonna
get tonya's take who is right here in
the audience and you say that you love a
mumbling man tanya
yes i do actually and he's sitting next
to me
[Applause]
so okay
what was the draw other than the
mumbling he was trying to ask me out he
was mumbling and i found it very cute
and attractive i felt like he was kind
of shy and some sensitive side in him
for some reason
three years later he asked me to marry
him he proposed and he mumbled again
can you do an impression how did he do
it well he couldn't say it but he wrote
it down in a little note and he gave me
some roses and he had the ring and then
he's like would you marry me baby that's
what i said on the note and i clearly
understood that's what he was asking
gus
why do you think that you just are so
darn charming
well first of all like i was really
nervous because she's so beautiful and
you know i just got i just started
uh mumbling and i couldn't get it right
and so when i wanted to ask her to marry
me i was like i'm gonna mumble again and
so i i wrote it down just in case so
that she can get the message
and
thank you tanya and gus this was so fun
it's our first official news in
hollywood i know and we got an audience
thank you guys we'll be right back
amazing
[Music]
all week
it's an all-out all-star hollywood
premier event
next drew
after two decades the cast have never
been kissed reunited i am josie
plus rue paul helps drew go back to
school and get her diploma
all new drew from hollywood
on the next drew barrymore show
[Applause]
two days ago welcome back all right it's
almost time to go but before we do we
love to leave you with a little
something to go and we like to call it
the doggie bag
there it goes
and today we're talking about a product
that i am a huge fan of and i hope you
guys are going to love it
what
uh
oh
[Applause]
i'm so happy to see you well i heard you
were shooting on the lot you know i've
been here so long i'm like the welcome
wagon so i brought you
a welcome basket
and you know your grandfather shot a lot
of movies here right
so i found some photos of him on the lot
here
so how about that that is so cool
that is so sweet
you know i i knew that he was here but i
i didn't have any photographic evidence
of it yeah well there you go and i've
got something even more special for you
this is amazing
you know he shot one of the most iconic
movies ever
this
is the original
poster for dr jekyll and mr hyde from
the 20s
i
am um
i'm going to put these up immediately i
love that you're going to be associated
with these
moments because you're bringing me
closer to my roots you're welcome and
thank you for being my friend and
welcome to the paramount lot do not park
in my spot
i will let you finish your show and do
what you do
well
thank you ross thank you dr phil
house calls with dr phil actually airs
wednesdays at 9pm on cbs and season 20
of dr phil airs weekdays and you check
your local listings for that i want to
thank all of our guests
and i feel so lucky and i
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
you